researchers in Massachusetts believe
they may be on the brink of creating a
revolutionary non addictive painkiller
it could be a big step forward in
dealing with the growing opioid crisis
it is called blue 181 and it was
developed by researchers at blue
therapeutics they've been working for
years to create a drug as powerful as
opioids but they claim without the
dangers Kenneth Craig sat down with a
team behind it for an interview you'll
see only on CBS this morning
Kenneth good morning good morning the
team at blue therapeutics says it wanted
to make a drug that is a total
replacement for the opioids currently on
the market something that people could
safely stop using without the possible
dangerous side effects and not many
people know they're addicts until they
start using mark Luce Sano
felt a gratification from painkillers
with his very first pill prescribed by a
doctor for a sports injury it was the
beginning of an opioid addiction that
consumed his 20s and nearly cost him his
life I ended up wrapping my my work
truck around the telephone pole one
night on my way home from work and that
wasn't even enough for me to stay clean
mark is now in treatment at st.
Christopher's in run by a ministry of
the Franciscan friars of the atonement
in garrison New York he's part of a
staggering number of Americans swept up
in the nation's opioid epidemic but now
these three Harvard trained scientists
believe they've developed a breakthrough
a non narcotic painkiller 50 times more
powerful than morphine but it's not
addictive we were told the same thing
about the painkillers currently on the
market that they were not addictive that
there's no risk for dependency and look
where we are now the onus is really on
all of us to make sure that the
scientific rigor is maintained the team
at Blue therapeutics is part of the
pharmaceutical race to find powerful
opioid alternatives they believe the
answer lies in their molecule blue 181
it works by clinging to a different
receptor in the central nervous system
than opioids eliminating the narcotic
high abuse and dependence risks it
targets receptors in the spinal cord
where you are able to reduce the
perception of pain without targeting
areas of the brain
leads to you know the addiction side
affects several other biotech companies
as well as researchers at universities
are working to develop similar drugs
with different approaches blue is
preparing for its first clinical trial
but the compound hasn't been tested in
humans yet dr. Robert Griffin
specializes in pain management it takes
a long time to really know all the
long-term effects and and really to
prove that something has no risk of
addiction over time blue 181 is backed
by more than two million dollars in
funding from the National Institutes of
Health and Department of Defense which
sees blue 181 as promising for injured
veterans especially vulnerable to
addiction and overdose do you see this
your concept as part of the solution to
combating the opioid epidemic absolutely
I think the opioid epidemic the main
driver of it is the fact that a lot of
us are in pain and if we don't give
effective painkillers we're never going
to solve the problem
blugh therapeutics says it could be five
years or so before the drug makes it
through clinical trials to see if they
confirm its claims the National
Institutes of Health and pharma a trade
group that represents US pharmaceutical
companies both say they are also working
to fund and develop non-addictive opioid
alternatives that could be
transformative for so many people just
when you said that I actually googled
because I wanted to see the number of
deaths from opioids which by last year
has surpassed the number of deaths from
Vietnam Iraq and Afghanistan combined
they've got to find an alternative and
when you look at the guy in our piece
who's been battling an addiction for ten
years he told me something like this
could have made all the difference in
the course of his life if he had the
option ten years ago no a lot of
interest there Thank You Kenneth